m
durant la crise que nous venons de
traverser cette crise sanitaire
historique
les maires ont été en première ligne
auprès de nos concitoyens en première
ligne durant le confinement pour le
faire respecter bien sûr mais également
pour préparer le déconfinement à
rillieux-la-pape ville que j'ai la
chance d'administrer depuis plus de six
ans désormais nous avons mis en place un
dispositif de soutien exceptionnel aux
commerces de proximité et aux petits
artisans
bien sûr ce dispositif vient en appui de
celui de la métropole de lyon de la
région auvergne rhône-alpes et le
dispositif de la ville de rieux est là
pour continuer à aider nos acteurs
économiques locaux à survivre à cette
crise et à survivre aux déconfinement
vous le savez les trésoreries de nos
acteurs locaux ont été mises à mal et le
but aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'y ait pas
de casse sociale de casse économique en
tout cas nous puissions la limite et
sans les maires sont les acteurs de
territoire cette crise ne pourrait pas
être surmontés
au-delà de ça vous vu nous avons mis en
place des dispositifs pour aider au
respect de la distanciation physique
dans les commerces
nous leur mettons à disposition des
commerçants nous mettons à disposition
des masques du gel hydroalcoolique et
nous sommes au quotidien à leurs côtés
pour faire en sorte qu'ils survivent à
cet instant tragique et que de l'autre
côté les habitants de nos territoires
puissent continuer à voir des services
de proximité
vous l'avez vu plus que jamais la france
a besoin de ces acteurs locaux des élus
locaux de terrain qui ont les pieds dans
la glaise chaque jour et sans qui rien
ne serait pas
[Musique]